you know wasn't that long ago the Keenan
Allen shared his views at the request of
Le'Veon Bell regarding Leon's latest rap
efforts ed Keenan Allen I got to keep it
banned bro this ain't it trashcan emoji
well hey you got to give Keenan Allen
credit he's gonna try to enter the fray
himself and now we can all use the
trashcan emoji or the fire emoji to
describe what we think of this
[Music]
you know for those of you watching on
NBCSN the facial expressions really make
this
I think he's undergoing some sort of a
painful medical examination not singing
that's my yeah I didn't know he was 40
let me just leave it at that
unbelievable that was yeah it's tough
too tough to criticize other people's
music and then get there and just wail
around like a like a cat in an alley
that's getting attacked or something
that was horrendous but we'll see what
lay beyond bail has to say about that on
Twitter meanwhile we have checked what
you have had to ask us on Twitter we put
out a call for questions and you have
responded we're gonna rip through as
many of them as we can let's start with
high at 81 with the release of kam
chancellor and Doug Baldwin there are
two fierce competitors being removed
from the sidelines and the locker room
on each side of the ball even if not
playing both had value as leaders how do
the Seahawks to replace those voices and
not miss a beat big cat it's gonna be
tough you know what this is what this is
why you pay Russell Wilson as much as
you paid him because it's not just the
play on the field russell wilson has to
control this locker room he has to be
the guy because you you are now the
seahawks over the last two seasons have
lost the team that won the superbowl has
lost the team that had that identity and
it's Russell Wilson's team now and this
happens in in football you see the
team's kind of transition you see all
the different teammates that Tom Brady
has had all the different teammates that
Ben Roethlisberger has had it comes down
to the quarterback and the coach to make
sure that this success that they've had
continues with a totally new crop of
guys but it's gonna be tough because
Doug Baldwin is an all-time competitor
kam chancellor the same it is going to
be difficult no one should say it's easy
well and what you autumn Utley do is you
have to have faith in your ability to
spot guys late in the draft or undrafted
like kam chancellor a sixth rounder like
Doug Baldwin who was undrafted and
developed those guys spot those traits
that you're looking for John Schneider
the GM of the team has proven that he
can find guys late in the draft or
undrafted Richard Sherman for crying out
loud was a fifth round draft pick so you
have to have faith that you can find
those
guys and you have to always take the
broader look at the makeup of your
locker room and you have to ask yourself
okay we we are moving on from a very
fiery opinionated personality maybe we
need to find a guy who is coming in this
year who has that that passion that he's
willing to wear on his sleeve to replace
what doug baldwin is taking away same
thing for the defensive side of the ball
where's our leadership gonna come from
we're not just looking for great players
we're looking for guys who will come in
and help compliment the players we have
and build a team Chris Sims always says
that at the Patriots front office they
have a sign that says we are not
collecting players we are building a
team and every time a guy exit who has a
unique skillset both from a football
standpoint and from a you know
leadership standpoint you have to think
who do we find to replace that guy what
that guy does and I think that's how the
Seahawks have to approach it I think
they have in the past which is why they
had a Doug Baldwin and a camp chancellor
neither of whom were all that heralded
coming out of school yeah I agree I mean
when you have a system set up when you
have a coach set up when you have the
quarterback set up the other things we
usually fall into place here and I think
the Seahawks have that string of success
that they can look back at and say this
is how we do it the Seahawk way so to
speak and they'll have success going for
because I trust Russell Wilson well and
look they're making him the highest-paid
player in NFL history at least until
Patrick mahomes gets his contract so
they have systematically built this team
around him over the past few years
they've gotten rid of the guys who kind
of resented him or didn't like him and
now it's all about Russell Wilson and
building that roster around him all
right next one comes from ATS Sean 1083
VA do you think Josh Rosen will have a
better career in Miami than Ryan
Tannehill who that's a good question
I'm gonna say yes because I what was
Ryan Tannehill career in Miami like what
was the the notable point I mean he
didn't even play in that in the playoff
game against the Steelers a few years
ago that was Matt Moore right am i right
yeah he had a very good 2016 season he
got hit low by coleus Campbell who was
with the cards at the time messed up his
knee and it was Matt Moore down the
stretch and into the playoffs I look
Ryan Tannehill lasted in that job for
seven years he got a second
contract for crying out loud I mean he's
he's the Jeff Fisher of quarterbacks he
just kind of survives at a level of
mediocrity don't give me that look you
know that I'm right oh you don't make
those jokes listen I am Tannehill
his career at the dolphins and you can't
you can't picture one huge moment you
can't picture like okay this was the
year or this is the Ryan Tannehill we
always make the joke next year's the
year he takes a step forward and it just
never came next year was always a year
he took a step forward it whether it be
injury or just bad play he never put it
all together and I think Josh Rosen will
have a better career with the dolphins
and Ryan Tannehill I'm still high on
Josh Rosen I'm still buying Josh Rosen
stock if you want to sell it I'll buy it
give it all to me how did you
characterize Tannehill career with the
dolphins what was that line is all he
every year was this is the year that
Ryan Tannehill is gonna take a step
forward this is the next year is the
step forward for Ryan Tannehill and you
can't you can't think of one if you hey
shoot Ryan Tannehill memorable moment
with the dolphins what do you think of I
don't know knee injury like there's
nothing but here's my point that kind of
summarizes Jeff Fisher's entire time
with the Rams no stop go get away get
away
III think that that Rosen has the
potential to be better than ten he'll
ever was the question is are they truly
all in with him or is he just a one-year
band-aid to see how they do this year
and whether or not they're in position
to draft to a tongue of Aloha
or someone else that they fall in love
with next year in the draft can that
fall in love with Josh Rosen quickly
enough that they don't get fascinated
with the idea of getting their own
rookie quarterback I think that's the
real question well that's up to Josh
Rosen if Josh Rosen wins football games
they won't be thinking we got to go get
two or we got to get Justin Herbert so
that's kind of you know Josh Rosen if
he's gonna get a shot as starting here
it's up to him if he wins football games
he will keep his job because they won't
be able to draft one of these guys next
year that seems like a franchise
quarterback and listen the Dolphins
might just be back into the Ryan
Tannehill where they're just like Josh
Rosen next year next year I don't know
it's it's a weird situation because I
honestly Brian tal is one of those guys
you may be you know what it was hard
knocks
hard knocks is
my memorable moment for Ryan Tannehill
just being on Hard Knocks there you go
and he didn't know the Chiefs were in
the AFC West I remember that the thing
about the Dolphins they've never
bottomed out they were seven to nine
last year we act like dolphins are one
of the worst teams in football you have
to bottom out one year to put yourself
in position to get that great
quarterback and the question is can they
find that great quarterback without
bottoming out and again it comes down to
Josh Rosen if he plays well in the team
plays well they won't be in position to
even get a Justin Herbert or to Otunga
bylaw all right at big Lou dog what's
next for Aaron Rodgers he's been banged
up the last couple of years and his 10
12 and 1 as a starter in his last 23
games new coach another year older less
mobile questionable attitude can t
bounce back will he ever make it to
another Super Bowl if not what's his
legacy big cat would he say about the
Bears chief rival quarterback I you know
I hate to say it but I really do think
Aaron Rodgers gonna have a fantastic
2019 a bounce-back year and I don't want
to make excuses for Aaron Rodgers but he
was injured week 1 against the Bears I
think that lingered for a little bit
there and this is a prove-it year
because Aaron Rodgers is a phenomenal
quarterback a Hall of Fame quarterback
but I think he had some humble pie last
year that big story comes out about the
dysfunction in Green Bay
will that be his legacy I think Aaron
Rodgers has an inner competitor to him
that says I don't want this to be my
legacy I'm gonna make this right so I
think Aaron Rodgers gonna have a very
good year I'm gonna say right now Aaron
Rodgers will go to one more Super Bowl
whether he wins it or not I don't know
he will go to one more Super Bowl before
he retires yeah look I'm surprised he
hasn't been to one more beyond the one
he was at nine years ago and only his
third season as a starter but I sure as
out for me all what Matt Lafleur does as
a head coach and and we've heard some
praise and I mean that's good it is so
far but it's meaningless until they
start playing games the challenge is
going to be getting the most out of
Aaron Rodgers getting the most out of
the team around him it could be moving
in the right direction they definitely
changed their philosophical approach to
acquiring talent there's a higher degree
of accountability there than we've seen
in recent years and I think Mark Murphy
is going to be the next one to go if he
can't turn this team into something
positive with Aaron Rodgers in his
remaining years
the team's quarterback but he's moving
toward that point where he's gonna have
a decline not all of these guys are
gonna play well into their 40s without
showing signs of where Tom Brady is the
aberration we'll see what Aaron Rodgers
can do all right another question from
Keith McClain seventy-eight assuming
Patrick mahomes improves as a
quarterback what's the over-under on his
yards touchdowns and interceptions this
season he had a top two or three
quarterback all-time season obviously
quite rare what can we expect
statistically while acknowledging he's a
better player in the year before see I'm
I'm gonna challenge the entire premise
of this question this question assumes
he's gonna be better this year I think
there's a chance he's gonna be worse
this year with or without Tyreke Hill
and there's a good chance he won't have
Tyree kill what we've had big cat is an
opportunity for entire offseason
for all the defensive coordinators on
the Chiefs schedule this year to spend
hour after hour coming up with ways to
stymie Patrick mahomes and we've seen
this before
whether it's the Wildcat whether it's
the read option whatever the flavor of
the month is the read the run-pass
option play whatever it is whether it's
a player or a scheme you spend eight
months trying to figure out how to stop
it and I think that the defenses are
gonna come up with ways to take some of
the steam out of Patrick Roy Holmes we
saw what the Patriots were able to do to
slow them down a little bit in the AFC
Championship game but I think mahomes
gonna take a step back this year not
because he's gonna be worse per se but I
think the defense is gonna be better
prepared on how to deal with him see I
think he's gonna take a step back just
because it's natural and he's not gonna
be bad but he's not gonna have 50
touchdowns because 50 touchdowns is an
incredible season so it's gonna be one
of those weird situations where I don't
think Patrick mahomes
is gonna be worse at all I think he just
won't have the same numbers that he had
last year because those numbers were so
I popping and so out of control and
everything had to go right that he's
probably gonna throw 45 touchdowns and
everyone will say well sophomore slump
hazard my home's threw five less
touchdowns no that's not 45 touchdowns
is a fantastic year it could probably
win him an MVP again but that's just how
good he was last year that it's only
natural for him to come down a little
bit regression to the mean and also
dealing with expectations last year we
went into the season not really knowing
what the Chiefs were going to be and
they were great this year they're going
to be expect
to be great right out of the gates and
if they stumble it all early on the vibe
changes he's struggling they are
catching up to him if he doesn't have
Tyreke he'll it could be a very
different year for the Kansas City
Chiefs are we're gonna take a quick
break what you're gonna be talking about
today plus maybe another Twitter
question or two as we wrap up this
Friday edition of pro football talk live
right after this
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports